this is a closely watched set of
negotiations though very private and not
for public consumption to the criticism
of so many people around the world and
those involved in the countries who are
going to be members of TPP is this one
of the main issues that are being
discussed well you know these
negotiations have to be closely held in
private so that they can do their job it
and negotiate the the key point here is
to get a deal that each of these
negotiators can get back to their
legislative bodies and can get approval
and so as soon as an agreement is
reached it will go back for approval and
and then that's when the agreement will
be made public and the public discourse
can can't take place transparently and
in public okay but of course a deal has
to be struck first atlanta this is
ground zero right now over the next
couple of days how likely are we going
to see a TPP deal after five years of
negotiations well it feels like that
there's real momentum but you know we
wait and we speculate and we wait some
more and we speculate some more but the
trade ministers I understand our meeting
now and they are in Atlanta with the
intent on closing a deal there are three
or four issues that are very tough but
there does feel like that there's
momentum and I'm a little greater than
fifty fifty-five percent chance that
we'll get a scene agreement out of out
of Atlanta this week well Jackson you're
a chairman of asia-pacific Council for
the American chambers of commerce
there's a lot of upside but there's a
lot of details that need to be hashed
out it looks like there could be one in
the auto issue forty-five percent of the
entire vehicle must originate to get
that TPP tariff exclusion it looks like
they're close to agreeing on that rule
how significant is that for countries
like Japan where
their supply chain extends outside of
Japan well a couple points on auto rule
of origins we learned in Maui at the end
of July that this was a major sticking
point especially between Japan and
Mexico and Canada the fact that they are
reaching an agreement at forty-five
percent i think is significant it's down
from the sixty percent threshold under
nafta but it's certainly higher than the
original thirty percent rule of origin
that Japan had had proposed so what you
see is that that is a spirit of
compromise and negotiation which is
exactly what's happening right now what
we want to see coming out of Atlanta the
other reason why this progress on rule
of origin I think is important is
because TPP at the end of the day after
it is approved is an aspirational
agreement and which means that it's open
for other countries to join and if you
set those thresholds on auto parts too
low what's the incentive on countries
like Thailand for joining down down the
road and in the future so I think that
nice compromise around forty five
percent if that's what I comes out of
the negotiations then it's it's should
be healthy for the agreement overall